وبالعوده مشاهدينا الى عمليه التخريب التي
شهدتها خطوط انابيب نوردا ستريم كانت مجله
الالمانيه كشفت الطريقه التي تم بها تفجير
خط نقل الغاز الذي يربط روسيا والمانيا
حسب المصدر فان التفجير الذي وقع في
سبتمبر الماضي نفذه فريق من الغواصين
يتحدثون لغه تبدو مثل البولنديه او
التشيكيه انطلقوا من يختن مؤجر يصل طوله
الى 15 متر ويحمل اسم اندروميدا وتم
متابعه مسار هذا اليخت في بحر البلطيق
بدءا من ميناء روسو الروسي في رستوك
بالمانيا في السادس من سبتمبر 2022 ثم
عبوره لجزيره روجن الالمانيه وصولا الى
جزيره كريستيانسو الدنماركيه على مقربه من
مكان الانفجار في السادس والعشرين من
الشهر ذاتي تشير التقديرات ان مئات الكيلو
جرامات من المتفجرات قد استخدمت في تفجيره
خط انابيب الغاز ولن يركز خبراء على وزن
المواد المتفجره فحسب لان الغواصين
المحتملين كانوا في حاجه الى معدات اخرى
حتى تساعدهم على التنفس تحت الماء اضافه
الى تجهيزات معقده واذا هذه النقاط رجح
الخبراء فرديه ان تكون مركبه بحريه اخرى
قد ساعدت اليخت من اجل انجاز مهمته وذكر
ان احد افراد طاقم اليخ كان يحمل جواز سفر
بلغاريا وهو جواز مزور في حين يواصل
المحققون الالمان جهودهم لتحديد الجنسيه
باقي الضالعين في التفجير كما يدرسون ايضا
اتهام حكومه الدوله ما بالمسؤوليه عما وقع